Speaker 1: All right.
I know many of you have been anxiously waiting
for the clips from the Herschel Walker debate
and the clips from the Marjorie Taylor GREENE
debate.
Let's get right into it.
Finally.
Finally, Georgia Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker agreed to do a debate with
the incumbent Democratic Senator, Raphael
Warnock.
Now, Herschel Walker humiliated himself during
this debate, not only with unintelligible
word salads, but also by pulling out a fake
police badge in a way that is historic.
Saturday Night Live can't even do anything
with it because how do you make a parody of
something that looks like a parody?
But also, Raphael Warnock didn't do particularly
well.
He didn't come across as particularly passionate.
He didn't come across as particularly prepared.
And he refused, presumably deciding that he
was not actually going to destroy Walker for
his incredible hypocrisies and incompetence.
And maybe he thought it would look better
to play it a little more polite.
I don't know.
And we will talk about it.
Here is the incredible moment in which Raphael
Warnock pointed out that Herschel Walker has
pretended to be a police officer and Herschel
Walker pulls out a fake badge and then is
admonished by the debate moderator, almost
like he's a little kid.
Speaker 3: One thing I have not done.
I've never pretended to be a police officer.
And and and I've never I've never threatened
a shootout with the police.
And now I have to respond to where we are.
We are moving on.
Gentlemen, respond to that.
And you know what?
So funny, I am with men and police officers.
Speaker 1: So he pulled out a badge there
for those of you who couldn't see.
And at the same time.
Speaker 4: Walker.
Mr. Walker.
Speaker 5: Excuse me, Mr. Walker.
Speaker 4: Out of.
Speaker 5: Respect, I need to let you know.
Mr. Walker, you are very well aware of the
rumors tonight.
Yes.
And you have a prop that is not allowed, sir.
I ask you to put that prop away where?
Speaker 3: It's not a prop.
This is real.
Speaker 1: And of course, she means a prop
in the sense of the debate that they have
an item.
Speaker 3: And he said, I have a problem.
And that is the law enforcement prop.
Speaker 5: Mr. Walker?
Yes.
Excuse me, sir.
You're very well aware of the rules, aren't
you?
Speaker 3: Well, are you aware he brought
up the chain?
Let's talk about the truth.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
So listen.
Nobody will ever actually respond like you
asked the Walker campaign to provide proof
or whatever.
There's never any explanation as to what that
is.
Every indication is that it's either straight
up a fake badge or what would be a real honorary
badge.
And honorary badge is nothing.
You don't flash it, and not an honorary badge
has no law enforcement meaning or authority
behind it.
It's just something you sometimes get if you
do like a ride along or a walk through of
some kind with police.
He also, after the debate, claimed that he
trained with the FBI.
And this I mean, it's Kafkaesque.
The the interviewer looks very closely at
the badge.
Speaker 3: So when I mentioned the FBI, you
know, people know all the joking, but I have
trained with the FBI.
Speaker 1: He was joking, but he did mention
meeting with the FBI.
Speaker 3: FBI, you know, people know all
the joking, but I have trained with the FBI.
I have supported many men and women in blue
for years.
This is not.
Speaker 4: What you were saying and.
Speaker 3: Not this is not something that
I just happen to do.
So they lied about it.
Speaker 4: So so this was this was a Johnson
County Herschel Walker.
Speaker 3: And that's not just one.
I have many bad.
Speaker 1: He has many badges.
Now, I have to tell you guys, all of this
stuff is meaningless, like civilians don't
train with the FBI.
There's not even any meaning to that.
They don't have any professional certification.
They can't act in any way.
Sometimes the FBI does what's called the familiarization.
When you've got an influential member of the
public where you like, you might do an obstacle
course or something like that.
You go to a shooting range.
It's not training at all.
And the idea that it connects to carrying
a badge in any way is just ridiculous.
Absolutely ridiculous.
Now let's get into some kind of substance,
even though it wasn't very substantive.
The moderators asked Herschel Walker, What
is one idea?
You have a specific idea to reduce inflation.
He just gives a word salad.
Speaker 4: You've been openly critical blaming
President Biden and the Democrats for inflation
and for the economy.
If elected, what is one idea?
One idea that you would champion to reduce
inflation?
We asked you to be specific.
You have 66.
Speaker 1: Good luck.
Speaker 3: Well, first of all, you have to
blame this administration in the Senate and
whatnot, because within two years this inflation
has gotten worse.
They are.
Speaker 1: Cut.
And, of course, it's gotten worse all over
the world.
And it doesn't seem to have anything to do
with Raphael Warnock.
Speaker 3: So energy independence.
They also raise taxes.
Speaker 1: Now, neither of those things are
true.
You look at oil exports and imports, and the
trade balance has not changed dramatically
since Trump left.
There has not been a tax increase.
Speaker 3: And at the same time the reckless
spending all our money.
So he will sit here tonight and say that he's
doing a good job for us.
And you asked me what is one job I would do
to help the inflation?
First of all, we've got to become independent,
energy independent again.
And the reason why are we going to our enemies
to ask for gas and oil?
And that puts us not just in a inflation problem,
but it put us on a national security problem.
And I think that's something that I think,
Senator, one, I need to realize and he mentioned
that he grew up here in Savannah.
Speaker 1: All right.
So he doesn't give an answer.
He doesn't.
There's no actual answer to the question.
Then in another completely unintelligible
moment, Herschel Walker says Americans have
to get off of government health care and get
on the health care that Raphael Warnock has,
which is, of course, government health care.
Speaker 3: Because if you have an able bodied
job, you're going to have health care, but
everyone else have health care is the type
of health care you're going to get.
And I think that is the problem.
And what Senator Warner, I want you to do
is depend on the government.
What I want you to do is get all the government
health care and get on a health care.
He's got a right.
Get you a better health care.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
A government plan.
That's that's what's fascinating.
Speaker 3: So that's what I'm trying to do
to make you independent.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Herschel Walker will make you independent
on health care by getting you off of government
health care and getting you on government
health care, which will make you independent
of the government.
It's pretty interesting.
Then here is Walker's rhetoric on abortion.
And again, when he is asked about this incredible
double standard wherein he claims to be against
abortion but also a paid for an abortion and
urged the same woman to get a second abortion.
It's all totally incoherent.
Speaker 5: Regardless of who wins in November,
will you accept the obvious?
Thank you very much, gentlemen.
Back over to you.
Speaker 4: Thank you.
And we turn now to the topic of abortion.
We're going to start with you, Mr. Walker.
A week before this debate, a former girlfriend
made public accusations saying you paid for
an abortion and that you encouraged her to
have another.
In an ABC News interview this week, you said
that the accusations are, quote, all lies.
For the voters watching tonight.
Can you explain the circumstances surrounding
these claims?
You have 60 seconds.
Speaker 3: Well, as I say, that's a lie.
And you know what?
Most thing I put I put it in a book.
One thing about my life is I've been very
transparent, not like the senator, easier
things.
But at the same time, I said, that's a lie.
And on abortion, you know, I'm a Christian.
I believe in.
Speaker 1: Life.
Right.
But you paid for the abortion.
Speaker 3: And I tell people this.
Georgia is a state that respects life.
And I I'll be a sinner to protect life.
And I said that was a lie and I'm not backing
down.
And we have Senator Warner people that would
do anything.
You say anything for his seat.
But I'm not going to back down.
Speaker 1: Because back down, from what.
Speaker 3: I see, is too important to the
Georgia people for me to back down right now.
Speaker 4: You've been vocally pro-life, supporting
a ban on abortions without exceptions.
Would you support a complete ban on a national
policy?
Speaker 3: That's not true either.
I say I support a heartbeat bill and I say
I support the Georgia heartbeat bill because
that's the bill of the people from Governor
Kim.
And that's why there that has exceptions in
it, as I am a Christian, but I'm also representing
the people of Georgia and that's who I represent.
Speaker 1: So yeah, so just continuing to
say that what appears to be an obviously true
story about him paying for the abortion and
urging a second one isn't real, but he won't
actually engage with the merits of it, which
is this is the mother of one of your kids,
right?
Yes.
Okay.
So and you were at one point in a relationship
with her, right?
Yes.
Are you denying she ever got pregnant or what?
Like, if it was actually subjected to some
questioning, it would almost certainly fall
apart now.
Two other notes on this.
The moderation in this debate was a disaster.
They gave easier questions to Herschel Walker,
presumably because they understood he couldn't
handle tougher questions.
But also Raphael Warnock did not do well and
I wouldn't be shocked.
Walker didn't fall apart partially because
Warnock didn't bring the heat.
And so it wouldn't shock me for the race to
get closer after the debate rather than actually
further apart.
So disappointed in Raphael Warnock's performance.
Walker's was, of course, a total disaster.